[Music]
okay so this is my spoiler free review
of the highly anticipated Amazon Prime
Show hunters which comes out Friday this
is actually held by David Weil who's
kind of a new face to the industry here
he is the showrunner creator of this and
he writes the first two episodes this is
also executive produced by Jordan Peele
who really can use a good produced show
in his belt after the disaster that was
Twilight Zone so when I got sent the
screeners I got sent five episodes so
I'm basing this off the first five this
is a ten episode season but with these
screeners came a note from David Weil he
was explaining how personal this story
is to him which got me very excited you
know it's coming from a place of deep
connection to the material there's
passion there you feel it in this letter
he wrote so I was really excited to dip
into this now let me just say the
premiere it's an hour and a half long it
could play as its own movie it is
spectacular the cinematography in this
episode alone felt game-changing on its
own it kind of felt like when I first
saw the cinematography in The Handmaid's
Tale or felt different it set such a
mood for the show and constantly kept
you on your feet in a good way not
distracting and this premiere has that I
mean you'll just notice it is a work of
art and how this cinematography is done
in this premiere episode so really take
it in and there's such heart to it it's
dark it's heavy-duty stuff in my head I
gave the premiere nine point eight I
thought it was almost perfect however
the person who directs the first episode
doesn't direct me into the other
episodes and you see the drop off and
also David wheel who is the creator and
main writer he does the first two
episodes and then dips out which always
frustrates me especially when it's your
first show you're really helming buying
you're saying it's personal to you write
the whole thing do a whole season why is
it that you only do two that really
frustrates me and you see the change in
quality in writing as well so as this
show goes on nothing comes close to
I saw on the premiere or maybe even the
tone I thought it was going to be it
goes from being just a very deep
personal story and unique in so many
ways to falling into another blend of
the boys and Watchmen and really any of
the Marvel Netflix type shows where it's
rated R type comic book story it's
gruesome but it's still hitting the same
plot points you got a detective here
who's in the middle of both sides with
these hunters and then these Nazis so
you're replacing really just super
heroes versus villains and it's this
group of Nazi hunters worse Nazis and
there's a detective trying to figure it
all out in the middle you've seen it
before it also is constantly quoting
comic books in the show that's clearly
inspired by but it gets tiresome in a
sense because we keep seeing this in so
many shows now the main gist of it being
about Nazi hunting is the unique part
but as it goes on you realize that's
really the most unique part of it all in
general it gets repetitive and a lot of
it you just feel like you've seen in
other shows just presented in a
different suit here I'm also very angry
when something seems like a complete
ripoff and this to me was actually with
the composer where if you were a big
leftovers fan you will notice there is
one song that the composer did here that
is a complete ripoff of one of the main
tunes of leftovers if you can catch that
let me know in the comments below I'd
love to see if you agree with me on that
cuz I think it's completely stolen and I
wasn't crazy about that it also suffers
from bloat I mean not one of these
episodes is under an hour they're long
it could definitely trim some fat here
it gets a little too self-indulgent in a
sense
I enjoyed that Ted Mosby from How I Met
Your Mother is getting work he's really
good as the comic relief here but he
still feels underwritten and that's
another problem I have where there's so
much weight given to the main character
but we have so many other characters and
in five episodes I still feel like I
haven't learned anything about them and
I still want to know more with more of
their character motivations and why
they're even doing what they're doing
so we'll see I mean I haven't seen the
next five so we'll see if that gets
sorted out now al pacino absolutely
kills it I thought he'd be one of those
things where he's in it for one episode
and disappears know he's ended a bunch
and he's great doesn't melt in one of
his best performances I've seen so it's
exciting to see him do this
the TV show the acting's good to all
across the board it's just certain
characters especially the lead character
here Jonah gets really annoying fast he
falls into that angsty teen branch but
more of like he's just a douche like you
don't like him and it's tough because
you started the most time with him he's
always angry and justice justifiably so
but to the point where the people should
even be nice to he's just awful and
annoying so that gets frustrating as
well
and a lot of the writing falls into that
writing that doesn't come off totally
natural here where a lot of characters
were just saying quotable things and I
say this a lot but it's like preaching
the sense of quotable things you'd hear
on Twitter that people say and a
character directly says this someone
you're like no one would ever say that
in a conversation so you fall into that
too and also in being a gruesome show
what was disappointing was the
choreography for the fighting it's
pretty stale it's not great I don't feel
any of the punches and I don't feel a
lot of these characters fight that well
so it's clearly got issues but I have a
feeling that this is a nice show in the
sense if you like comic book shows
you're gonna like this show it fits in
with the Daredevils of the world it fits
in with the boys it's good but if you're
looking for something that changes the
game and brings all audiences in it's
not this show it isn't the premiere
you're gonna watch from here and be like
wow this is incredible but you'll see as
it goes on it kind of just dips into
everything else you've kind of been
tuning in to accept the change being
okay we're doing nazi hunting which is
cool it's that's unique but I just wish
the way they presented it was more
unique in the end it's masking that
you're kind of seeing something you've
seen a hundred times over but overall
for the five episodes I saw I would give
this a solid eight point four it was one
of those shows was really hard to rate
because there was just points I'm
watching and I'm like the whole time
like do I really like this I don't know
like I'm being honest with you like
again I love the premiere and then after
that I was like I really want to like
this and I think it's okay I don't love
it it's not something I can sit there
and be like this is amazing
I feel like we're gonna say it's amazing
because you're excited at seeing these
new type of faces going on these new
type of villains you don't see
in this way in the comic book II
landscape of it it feels like it's based
off a comic and it isn't but underneath
all of that
it's formulaic and I just don't care
enough because it's just revenge revenge
revenge revenge and it loses its soul a
bit so we'll see maybe the last five
episodes bring it back up again
but that's why I'm gonna say four
hunters I definitely suggest if you like
that type of thing with comic book
check this out you're gonna dig it and
if you like it see you Nazis get killed
who doesn't you'll like it too but don't
expect this incredible show temper your
expectations after the premiere let me
know down below if you plan on watching
it I love to hear your thoughts please
make sure you subscribe to my channel I
review a bunch of TV shows I also do
celebrity interviews as well so you
don't wanna miss those and please follow
me at Steve arleigh 1 on Twitter and
scram for more of me I'll see you next
time